you
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the
presentation so we'll have three talks
in the decision first talk semantic
matching against corpus new application
and method presented by Lucille n so the
talk will be for 20 minutes thank you
okay awesome thanks um so yeah hi I'm
Lucy and anybody talking about if it
will come back semantic matching against
text corpora and this is in
collaboration with Scot miles and Noah
Smith at the University of Washington
so we've clearly made a lot of recent
advances in modeling sentential
semantics like a lot of the nli tasks
semantic similarity paraphrase etc and
so what we're the proposed is that a
natural thing to do is to match natural
language propositions against the corpus
and what we see and use possible end
users as for example historian of
science being interested in tracking the
idea of vaccines cause autism you might
expect a spike in that in news after say
the Andrew Wakefield article about that
similarly I political scientists might
be interested in how different framings
of policy issues occur or public
servants dealing with recovery after
national disasters might be interested
in ideas about well-being or recovery so
this is kind of a use case we imagine
where a user specifies a query like
dealing with authorities it's causing
stress and anxiety we would query the
corpus return a list of matched
sentences for example those in charge of
recovery or making a movie of peace
anger among home earners and at the end
of the talk I'll briefly touch on what
we might be able to do with elicit match
sentences which is to maybe have it like
proxy measurement across a variable like
time so and this is kind of related to
as I mentioned work on at ailment so my
text alert but there's also related work
in information retrieval specifically
positive table for question answering
and also kind of on
inside its in similar spirit to dynamic
topic models and related work so how
this is gonna go I'm going to kind of
formalize this a little bit and then
talk about two different applications
one which in which we use examples from
a code book and this is kind of the
media framing domain and in a second in
which we have our domain expert Scott
specify queries of ideas like he's
interested in in disaster recovery and
then we did a user study to validate
that and see if they're under interested
end users and finally I'll briefly
discuss this using the output for
measurement idea so basically as inputs
we would have a corpus of sentences
which will say C and a proposition query
containing the idea of interests which
we'll call SP and we'll just treat these
as sentences um we're not going to
consider document structure in this work
but would be interesting a future work
and what we would like to do is
basically score all these sentences s
and C such that the score should be high
if and only if s expresses the
proposition quarter SP and from there
you can get the top end sentences and
return out an alpha list so I'm gonna
talk about this first application where
we're gonna use the media frames corpus
which is contains thousands of articles
about different policy issues the one
worth of focus on is immigration and
spans of text are indicated with
different frame any dimensions and this
could be these are things like if the
issue is cast in legal terms in economic
terms quality of life and so on and we
also have the annotation code book for
that corpus and we're gonna take 30
annotation codebook examples as the
ideas of interest and when example this
is immigration rules have changed
unfairly over time which invokes this I
kind of framing of fairness inequality
with relation to immigration immigration
and so the idea basically is that if we
match a sentence if we imagine an
example sentence from the code book then
should it should evoke the frame that
we're expecting that it's an example of
and just as a side note there are many
ways to evoke a frame outside the
codebook so we're not really looking for
like high recall at all we're just kind
of looking at precision here so because
we're looking frames and it's kind of
like a broad category where they use a
really simple scoring function and
basically what we're gonna do is each
sentence we're gonna represent as the
average of its of its word factors and
then we're getting Co sine similarity
between the two sentence vectors and
that's going to be the scoring function
and we use we try out two different
where vector variants that are
pre-trained one are periphrastic word
vectors by whiting at all and these are
trained on the ppb they're kind of
designed to be used in these sorts of
similarity tasks and the other is the
very well-known work Tyvek pre trained
on Google News and the nice thing about
these is that because they're trained on
such a large data they might have a lot
of entities we're interested in so we're
interested in how well does our output
line up with the corpus annotations so
we look at this at the sentence level
where if we match if we match this
sentence does the frame line up with the
the annotated frame and what we find is
basically that the periphrastic vectors
do better than the words of executors
which in turn do better than just a
tf-idf baseline and so we're not really
looking for they're clearly probably
better methods to do this to get much
higher precision but this is kind of a
first step and does really well give it
how simple it is so there we go
secondly I'm going to talk about
matching more specific queries and this
is gonna be in a domain where
researchers and public servants don't
necessarily have a lot of empirical data
and they want to understand what
challenges the community is facing as
kind of a post-mortem post-disaster
sort of work
and so our thinking is that we can use
um used to these techniques to find
relevant sentences from which they can
how much they can learn from and so
we're gonna specifically focus on the
Canterbury earthquakes New Zealand from
2010-2011 we pulled a corpus of sorry of
about a thousand news articles that were
local from local news sources and we as
ideas of interest we had our domain
expert Scott provide 20 queries like he
was he's interested in for some work and
these are things covering community
well-being infrastructure of decision
making utilities so on for example the
council should have consulted residents
before making decisions it seems obvious
apparently it's not to certain
governments and so in this case unlike
in the framing case we're really
interested in kind of more finding great
matching really want to match this idea
and so because of that we're going to
hear use a more entailment sort of model
it's gonna be based on syntax and I'm
gonna walk through it very quickly so
given two sentences on the candidate
sentence from the corpus and the
proposition
query we're gonna get the dependency
parses of each we're then gonna find a
sequence of what we're calling tree
operations which transform one tree into
the other and so the intuition basically
is that the difference between the two
sentence is somehow indicate the
relationship between the two if it's
saying back to each other if they don't
and this syntactic transformation is one
way of kind of getting at that and to be
more clear we can take this example
where we start with the sentence on film
a bureaucratic systems are causing
stress and we want to find a set of
transformations such that we end up with
this tree at the bottom and so you might
want to delete a couple of the words
read label and then finally insert
you get the entry and I'm not gonna go
into details about how we do this by
it's basically a greedy search from
there we use that sequence ties features
into a classifier the original paper
from hilum and Smith's that we worked
off of use the logistic regression
classifier with based on counts of
features
this is 2018 so we're gonna also put
into a neural networks it's a sequence
and we should and we just trained it on
SNL I stand for natural inference
natural language inference corpus and
just kind of on a two-class entail
versus neutral contradiction and so to
make this run in a reasonable down time
we first do this this fast word vector
based matching on an entire corpus
obtain some subset of matches from which
we then run this entailment based model
and we tried out different combinations
of this so to evaluate we serve a twenty
emergency managers and took the output
of the different systems and had them
rate from one to five how good of a
match they were to compare to the query
so an example that we showed them is
there's a shortage of construction
workers and so one is like this is not
really expressing the idea at all to
five which is hey this is great and so
what we see is that on the left or the
left you are basically we use the
periphrastic vectors in this like first
pass filter and then they're kind of
between the two sides that are the
budget logistic regression analyst him
versions of the syntax paste model and
in general the periphrastic vectors
again do better than to work effect ones
and this makes a difference on kind of
like what you do afterwards basically if
you have kind of mediocre output from
that first pass you're not really gonna
make things better we also asked
respondents if they're just interested
in this application in general most of
them said yes which is great and then
half of them we're actually interested
in a follow-up study which is it
progress and basically we're having them
specify their own idea queries and so
it's kind of like this back and forth
study which is cool um
so finally I'm gonna talk about using
this sort of matching output in a
different sorry using this output and
like a measurement and what I mean by
that is say we have this query dealing
with the stories is called a stress in
anxieties I've been kind of using
service talk and if we take its ok there
we go if we take the top 50 sentences we
look at the metadata for the articles
they came from they're published on a
certain date um which kind of indicates
oh hey this idea is showing up its time
and it's so if we bunk if we've been
this in three months we get the
following
um histogram and so we show this to sky
and he was like oh this is interesting
that's kind of worrisome unfortunately
it's like way doubt reboot and basically
I after the earthquake happens which was
kind of point 11 ish people are still
kind they're still feeling okay about
the fact that they're getting help the
government's being involved in giving
aid in terms of recovery services etc
and as time goes on worry and stress
starts to set in because their needs
aren't being fulfilled or they feel like
they're being forgotten and then so that
translates into
subsequent coverage so some things that
we found for both studies um that kind
of motivate future work are one the
complexity of an idea so some inquiries
that are too general to specific that
impacts the kinds of matched sentences
you get and also can we give user
guidance for maybe running better
queries so that's kind of a progress
with this
follow-up study so another problem we
kind of ran into was entity / Co
reference this is particularly
interesting in the New Zealand
earthquake data because a lot of those
entities just they don't they're local
they don't really show up in our news an
example this is Sarah which is the
Canterbury Earthquake Recovery Authority
and apparently also the last name of an
actor who I didn't know existed finally
they're just the fact that we're using
we're kind of breaking off sentence
boundaries is a is a limiting factor so
in two ways one the surname context can
invalidate a match and secondly a
potential match can be kind of spread
across a sentence boundary so we'll miss
it and so this so in future work um it
would be interesting to incorporate that
or document structure so on so yeah so
uh just to wrap up in this talk we
showed the kind of viability of
different semantic matching methods and
to two pretty different application
domains we performed the user study to
establish some end users are interested
at least in this particular application
and motivated future work on semantic
matching and other measurement
applications Thanks
[Applause]
yeah except it's to ask would you write
good freeze how do you value what is
better query and what is sure so you're
asking basically um so how we're how
we're getting them to write to write
better queries and help me might your
value might guys yeah so we're so when
this fellow study were not we're be we
basically asked them like what would you
like what would you write as a query
without being without giving suggestions
and they're they're actually somewhat
different from the ones that Scott
provided um and so it's probably gonna
be more of this back and forth thing of
us seeing how well what kind of output
we get from these new queries um how
well they score in terms of like it
expect it out but that they want to see
and then going back and being like oh
well maybe you should simplify this I'm
in the future does that make sense yeah
more questions of time
about your complexity about the new find
and defuse of the same name
okay I'm this is gonna be a problem
across a lot of thanks what is your
guys's idea for handling that in the
next project so the question is how will
we plan on handling kind of entities
that share the same name but maybe just
appear in different domains I'm not sure
yet to be honest I mean one thing we can
think about was kind of getting a small
amount of label data on the target
domain and then doing a little bit of
domain adaptation any sort of stuff to
make not perhaps less of a problem but
that's all still kind of progress
anymore just an interesting or maybe
more of a comment one thing that might
be interesting to play with is there's a
corpus of CNN and Daily Mail articles if
you've encountered that I've seen it
okay so they have the highlights of the
article and then the article itself and
so it's an abstract 'iv assigned Ernest
that could relate to that that could be
a fun right yes and training daily yes
so I guess the comment if people didn't
hear was that the CNN Daily Mail corpus
would be an interesting thing to apply
this to so I have a question so the
questions if we tried other methods
besides just kind of simple addition of
the word vectors and the kind of stuff
basic word vector matching so yeah and
um so this it was kind of motivated by
that whiting paper wit in which they had
found that still are averaging for the
directors had actually worked better as
I'm using ring it's really nice to him
or something um I think they since have
subsequent results which
have kind of modified that and so I
would probably try something else in the
future but one thing that's nice about
it is just how really how simple is and
it still gives a decent signal any more
question okay the things that be good
again nothing unnatural noise so so hi
this is some joint work we'll be
presenting that I did with so I'm Jana
ton sorry I'm doing this is present with
you on a time and the as mentioned this
is our talk a synthetic and natural
noise both break neuro machine
translation what I've gone ahead and
done for you here is I've just left in
where the spell checker has decided
there's an error so that's all these red
lines and and the beautiful thing is you
might be thinking well maybe people make
typos these are actually all real
mistakes that people have made so what
we did this is from a wiki edits corpus
so I just went ahead and swapped in the
mistakes that people make and you might
be thinking well not to worry
machine translation is is really robust
you know spell checkers are really
robust first I'll run that and see what
what it fixes so not to worry what we
end up with is a much better version so
synthetic ant natural noise doth break
neural machine in translation and it's
also figured out my pseudonym which is
Yucatan busk so we've made a lot of
progress here it's also much more
Shakespearean which I feel like gives it
a sort of gravitas that was missing from
the title so so clearly spell checking
is sort of not perfect it's it's nice
and English in particular we have a lot
of did you mean kind of data so that
really helps and then obviously here's
the actual title here are actual names
so the the sort of basic you know place
where the situates in the literature
right is in this context of things like
adversarial exam
and we're very familiar with this kind
of classic example from the vision
literature right where you have an image
which was classified as a panda you add
what is seemingly sort of imperceptible
noise and now you have a Mis
classification and the question becomes
sort of what does that look like for
natural language and what sort of
important important right is that the
noise distorts the perceptual process in
some way but it doesn't actually hinder
the semantic understanding so maybe you
did notice that the second image was a
little bit blurrier but it didn't
actually affect your ability to
understand what it was and this is not a
typical right of our perceptual system
so for example our eyes all saccade all
over the place all over the all the time
and they sort of give you a little bit
of that this is not in the paper but
some work we've been doing since then if
you take some some text you go ahead and
introduce the same kind of errors that I
showed earlier so here we have a lawsuit
was filed March 27th and the preliminary
investigation was opened by the
prosecutors first of all it's important
to note that no one has any trouble
reading this and just to prove that
point we went ahead and run an eye
tracker so we have people sit down and
they're actually reading the sentence so
we have a sort of fixate here they jump
a little bit move forward an entire
phrase back track and then move through
the rest of the sentence the the only
reason this is really important is that
there are 14 words there are nine
fixations so when people are reading
this text and we actually have them
answering questions at the end to make
sure that they did comprehend the text
they're not paying a lot of attention to
a lot of the words in fact based off of
what we know about how much you see when
you look at a specific part of the of
the sentence what it probably happened
in this fixation is they saw the entire
word completely skipped was and then
moved on right so they probably didn't
even notice which we see for instance
there's some interesting work in the
psyche literature where you interview
people didn't even notice that there was
an error there and we do this all the
time right we make mistakes in our own
writing
we then reread it and totally miss it
and we need a new pair of eyes to notice
it so sir so perception is sort of
fundamentally noisy and sparse and so
maybe the reason that we aren't
disturbed by these kinds of adversarial
examples is because we've been sort of
training on it our entire lives another
place you might be training on these
things is messy handwriting right your
entire life you're trying to decipher
doctor's notes or
other kinds of things maybe your child
wrote you may yourself have really messy
handwriting and so I went ahead and did
some some research I went online and I
searched and it looks at like if you
have missing handwriting you might have
emotional baggage so that you know just
just take that home on the other hand I
did continue searching and if you go
further down on the results you might
also be a genius
so it's a little unclear what the
research shows there but either way
you've probably been exposed to noisy
texts throughout your life so what we're
doing in this setup is I'm just going to
give you like the super quick we have a
bunch of models which we're gonna test
and see how brittle they are and how
noise affects them so first we use NEMA
test which is a machine translation
framework which performed very well on a
bunch of WMT tasks from last year it's a
bpe based representations if you're not
familiar that just means that instead of
using words as input and sort of finding
sets of characters cuz they so for
instance like a morphological ending
like ing gets chunked out so this is a
really helpful way of increasing
robustness to add vocabulary effects
we're then also going to use this work
from tackle last year char to char this
is a very impressive model that it
doesn't even take into account
segmentation information so it just
treats the entire input as one big
character stream and then and then
translates to characters and then
finally just as a simple baseline what
you might code up in an afternoon
so this is kind of your sequence of
sequence model with attention and
character based convolutions for the
representation so it's not super
important the thing to keep in mind is
just that this final model here and has
notions of what word boundaries are but
looks at individual characters this
model doesn't even care about word
boundaries and this top model has maybe
slightly more intelligent ways of
figuring out sort of morphological units
and so forth and then for the data we're
going to use a spoken text corpus
so therefore the iaws LT composition a
couple years back they had a bunch of
these TED talks and their translations
and so that's what we're going to do the
evaluation and then also some of the
training I'll show you so first let's
talk about synthetic errors so the
beauty of adversarial examples that
exist for instance in the vision
literature is that you basically can
just sample random noise so what would
that look like for us if we wanted to
just automatically create
well something we do all the time is we
swapped you letters right you're typing
you type to quickly you flip to letters
so we're gonna restrict that to being in
longer words and only in the middle of
the word so sort of make it a little
easier but noise goes to nosy or
something there's a meme that you might
remember for many years back according
to research at Cambridge if you scramble
all the letters in this word or
something to this effect you can still
read it as long as the first in the last
letter stay put so we're gonna pretend
like the Internet knows things and we're
gonna go ahead and and follow the meme
for our second type of noise third what
if we just ignore that and randomly
permute all the letters in the word and
then finally all the time we end up
hitting a key by accident so what
happens if we swap one of the letters
with one which is within a radius one
key on the keyboard and the effect of
this on these two on the sort of the two
pre-trained you know state-of-the-art
fancy Mazal models is that as you've
changed the number of tokens that are
per muted or that are messed up you see
the blue scores drop off not terribly
surprising and what we see for example
is that by the time we get to something
like twenty percent we've actually lost
you know almost half of our performance
right ten percent is even is still a
pretty steep drop-off in both of these
models so it doesn't take a lot to mess
with translation I'll come back to what
we might do about it a little bit later
the second thing you might ask is well
these are some nice synthetic results
what does it look like if we actually
try to use real noise so I said you we
have some wiki edits and stuff like this
so it turns out that there are some some
beautiful people out there that have
created these collections of sort of
second language speakers in there and
edits to them writing essays Wikipedia
corpora stuff like this and so we can go
and we can find a bunch of naturally
occurring errors in the wild and then we
can use them to permute our text I don't
speak a word of German but I'm told that
what's going on here is that for
instance we have phonetic distinctions
like T and D s and z are getting getting
screwed up
we have dropped letters like the T
missing and babysitter here and then we
kind of get into the more interesting
space which is things like morphological
problems right so where someone has has
conjugated something incorrectly this is
kind of stuff where if we really want to
be able to do this automatically we're
gonna have to have a much maybe stronger
notion of linguistics to do it than the
kind of simple errors I was presenting
before so the question becomes do these
errors affect our models in the same way
that our synthetic errors do yes so all
I've done here is I've gone ahead and
superimposed the this is the natural
error line on both of these it's just a
hair better so maybe it's the case that
there are certain types of errors that
are less likely to be made then just
willy-nilly swapping or randomizing of
letters so for example maybe people are
less likely to mess up a capitalization
maybe people are less likely to mess up
you know they they may choose the wrong
conjugation but at least it's a valid
conjugation these kinds of things right
so there's a there's a quite a bit more
exploration that's necessary there the
other thing is that we don't have full
token coverage because for example and
it we just don't have errors for every
single word so this this maxes out at
about 40 percent okay so as I started
with though we have spell checkers so
like obviously I said they're not
perfect but like they're probably like
not terrible so here's what happens with
our French German and Czech models if we
just introduce a bunch of natural errors
so here are blue scores and here's what
happens if we just select the first
spell checker suggestion for every
single word in the in the in the
scrambled urge to be in the air-filled
corpus so what you first note is that
first French and German we are seeing
pretty significant gains something's the
tune of five to six blue points so spell
checkers are doing something the other
thing though that I should mention is
that in the case of French and German
you're only seeing typically one to two
suggestions from the spell checker for
each one of those recommendations that
is not the case for check right so when
you look at the check errors what ends
up happening is you have this insane
list of all the things that could
possibly happen again I don't speak any
Czech so I just picked the first one and
it turns out that actually on average I
made things worse so that's sort of not
you know maybe for the
small error condition given sufficient
contacts or rich spellchecker will be
beneficial but those are also going to
break down and then just as a reminder
these are still quite a bit different
from what it would be like if you just
trained and tested on clean text so
excuse me so now let's try to see if we
can do maybe something about robustness
so what about training with noise so
there's way tuning many numbers and so
if you're really bored we've just put
charts and charts in the paper so I'm
going to try to synthesize a couple of
quick lessons from it so one is if I
train on noisy text but I click but then
I test on clean unadulterated text how
do I do so here what we've done is these
are the different types of vanilla is
completely clean here are the different
types of noise that I mentioned earlier
and here's what happens I sort of
ensemble's on the noise and for French
and checked so that this doesn't get too
cluttered here's sort of ideally where
we would like to be this these lines and
how well are the models actually doing
and the thing that I want to point out
is that the natural errors are actually
quite a bit harder for some reason so
despite the fact that we you know this
is this is insane right here I've
literally scrambled the entire word and
that doesn't affect the model as much
when testing on the original data as
when I introduce natural errors so
there's something that we still need to
investigate there another thing though
that is somewhat heartening is that you
know at least once you take the natural
and you add other noise to it then the
model becomes sort of more generally
robust another thing that I'll point out
very quickly is what happens if you test
on all different types of noise so here
what I've done is we've trained on a
specific type of noise and then I'm
presenting the average blue across five
different types of noise for testing so
for instance just to make this concrete
here we just do the letter swap inside
of those words but the blue score here
is when you test on swap middle random
keyboard natural so all of those and
then in an average the first thing that
I'd like to point out is that the model
does seem in some sense to have a
robustness they're sort of the direction
of robustness right so if a model is
trained on where
that are totally randomized then it does
better on average including on things
that were that where Jesse swaps then if
it only see if it sees less noise and
this seems to sort of hold over to the
ensemble case right so once I throw just
tons and tons of different noise at it
the model seems to do the best sort of
overall all right so what you would like
to do right so if I was sort of like
amazing at cognitive modeling somehow I
would build a model which not only took
into account noise but also just like
was impervious to it just didn't care we
tried a bunch of fancy things and they
didn't work and I can talk about self
attention he type things later well so
what ended up sort of seeming to be fine
was let's just try the mean character
representation so if I have a model
whose word representation is just
literally the average of the vectors for
all the characters then it doesn't
matter what order they're in right so
like it's by definition resilient to
this so there's the good news it means
that I can train on completely clean
text with no errors I can present it
completely scramble text and it still
does okay it's like a twenty percent hit
not the end of the world and then the
thing that's not surprising to anybody
in this room who's ever thought about
language is that there are
morphologically rich languages for which
turns out you really don't want to just
average all the characters there's
something in the structure of the word
so that's that's clearly not the
solution as one final note though so I
think I do want ideally to be able to
move in this direction right I'd like to
be in a situation where models are sort
of more inherently robust and so one
thing we wanted to do is at least kind
of analyze what the filters of the model
we're learning when we're sort of
showing at various types of noise so
it's a little bit hard to interpret all
of this but let me just sort of figure
focus on one point this is what happens
if you look at the weights in all of the
filters that are learned for the
character embeddings and our models when
they're trained in these four different
settings with keyboard errors natural
errors completely randomized ordering of
the letters in the word and the ensemble
note that these have pretty high
variance right so you're learning
different so different filters are going
to be firing for different settings for
different
and then note that when you train on
random they've completely collapsed and
so what we think is happening here is
that basically when you completely
randomize the input like that the models
basically rediscovering that mean
character model from before it's
basically giving up on trying to learn
structure and so it just takes some sort
of an average of everything that's in it
and then moves forward so that seems to
be kind of like a baseline default maybe
we are even doing something like that
but we have additional systems which can
trigger if we're not understanding right
so we can reason about things we can
sort of piece together how we might
unscramble a word and so forth so that's
kind of where we'd like to move in terms
of future research Thanks we have time
for questions thanks for a great talk so
have you thought about what would be in
the scenario and adversarial noise like
what would really screw up the system
like for the image processing there were
like random would sometimes cool is
there like an adversarial thing which
was real so it depends on what you mean
so there's kind of two versions of
adversarial right so one is can you just
break all these systems like obviously
you can break all these systems what we
didn't do that we played around a little
bit it's just very time-consuming there
are cases right where if I change one of
the letters I will change the
translation and so it's quite possible
that some of the if I wanted to trick a
translation system for example into
saying something in particular I might
be able to make some changes on the
input which would cause that but which
the human wouldn't think of as as the
facting it and that's I think sort of
the ideal adversarial case I don't have
a great notion for it we tried to do
that manually and we were able to find
some examples I don't have a pipeline as
of yet but I think that would be yeah
it'd be awesome if you could come up
with these kinds of these kinds of
examples yeah
hi great talk
I'm an Kyle from Boeing we deal with a
lot of very noisy tax data for example
McKenna's over the world maintained a
airplane and they write poorly so really
interesting your talk so did you try to
deal with abbreviations the chop off
some the letters and sometimes they
insert letters too
yeah so we didn't explicitly though
anything actually skipped it one of the
they're not exactly abbreviations but
definitely omissions is pretty common in
the Edit corpora so it is pretty common
for people just a completely miss a
letter for example which is kind of
starts to get at this but no
particularly Fritz is in an abbreviation
you have even less to go on so I don't I
suspect will just make everything even
even harder but I don't have an answer
to what - I don't have an answer did you
what to do about any of this but but i
but I don't yeah that's a great that's a
great problem also do you have a sense
how much misspelled words involved
before you were really not able to do as
well
percentage-wise in a sentence yes sir
it's it becomes very clear so we all we
all have our experiences with machine
translation right where we run something
through and then we it even even in the
best of cases we still have to do some
detective work to figure out what was
actually intended right so in that sense
yeah even if like that 10% mark if I'm
just if I'm just basically imagining of
a sentence and now two of those words
have something randomly new the
detective work becomes very very
difficult to figure out what was
actually going on I there's a there's an
example for instance in the paper where
we run one of these kind of fully
scrambled things through Google
Translate and you kind of get out and
then also the output from these other
systems and you get out these sentences
and in some cases the models default to
sort of copying they're like oh well
I'll just take the German straight
through and just hand it back to you and
in some cases you get what it's attempt
is out of sentence it's just that it's
completely meaningless but you
it has no bearing to what was originally
there so I think the answer is probably
not a lot and maybe a spellchecker will
be able to help you but I also want to
note that there's a huge difference
between spell checkers right so there's
a difference between like for instance
the Google Translate spell checking that
we were doing here and if you run like a
spell on your UNIX machine so so having
some sort of central contacts is really
important to being able to address those
errors yeah ok any more questions for
your corpus of natural errors I noticed
you had some that were the Wikipedia
typos that were probably from native
speakers but then you also had language
learners right and from a linguistic
standpoint the errors made by language
learners tend to be rather different
from natives so I was wondering if you
looked into how those differ and and
anything about that no unfortunately we
were mostly focused on just finding
these errors but you're absolutely right
in the case of I have to double-check
the details I think in the case of the
German and the Czech those are both
language learners and then in the case
of French and English
those are wikipedia edits and I think
that's partially just an issue I mean as
its availability right there just isn't
as much of that kind of stuff but I
think that that's another sort of
fascinating thing right is that if we
were to build these models ideally that
a robust we'd like to be able to
introduce these kinds of errors that
require someone to first collected or
found all these signs of things and as
as resources you know as the language
becomes not English resources you know
good so yeah
[Applause]
so this is talk in this session why
swapper she will talk about syntactic
scaffold for cement extractions hi I'm
suave ah can you hear me okay yeah and
I'll be talking about syntactic
scaffolds for semantic structures and
this is work done jointly with my
co-author Sam this trade here and Kenton
do Chris and no Alex right there
lots of affiliations literally too many
loggers alright so the tasks we are
interested in is semantic structure
prediction now depending on the
formalism these semantic structures may
look very different for example we have
the sentence
evanka I told Faye Faye that she is
inspiring the frame semantics structure
for this sentence look like it looks
like this there are two frames of
meaning one about the event telling and
another about the event subjective
influence for the telling frame the
speaker is evanka the addressees Feifei
and the message is that she is inspiring
and for this objective influence frame
the entity is she and she is providing
the influence so this is what frame
semantic structures look like a
different kind of structure is given by
a core efference where you have in green
all the entities which are present in
the sentence as well as relationships
between the word she and Faye Faye
hopefully she refers to favor here but
yeah so this is the kind of structure
that you get from core efference chains
so as you can see these structures look
very different the frame semantics looks
quite different from the correct
structure but what they have in common
is the syntactic framework so for
example we have this in the constituency
tree for the sentence the same sentence
and we can see that the different
arguments speaker is
non phrase addressee is also a non trace
and the message is an is an esper so
what you can see from here is that if
you have the syntactic information of a
sentence it might be easy to get to the
semantics of the sentence and indeed
this has been tried extensively in
previous work so prior work involves
using a pipeline where given a sentence
you first do the syntactic processing of
the sentence to get the full syntactic
tree use features from that tree to
extract the semantic graphs from it now
the problem with this is that it is both
very expensive and since you're doing
things in a pipeline you're very likely
to cascade errors if you get the syntax
wrong you're very likely to also get the
semantics wrong also the tree that we
saw in the previous example is very more
complicated whereas the semantics was
relatively simple like Yonatan said when
people read sentences if they are trying
to semantically understand the sentences
they did not read through the entire
sentence some words can be skipped some
words are semantically vacuous and so on
so using syntax in a pipeline works but
it is probably not the best solution now
in recent times people have come up with
neural end-to-end models which have
completely done away with syntax so
these end-to-end models just start with
the sentence and try to predict the
entire semantic graph from the sentence
now even though these models work
regardless of not using syntax it has
not been conclusively shown that syntax
does not help further in fact people
from Europe Liu Heng who somewhere over
here showed in her paper that using
constraints from gold syntax actually
helps so there is still hope first in
fact there is actually a lot of hope so
what we are suggesting in this work is
somewhere in between these two worlds we
want to use syntax but we don't want to
go through this whole
of pipelining and errors cascading and
so on
so what we are suggesting is called
is this method called syntactic
scaffolds which uses as the name
suggests suggests syntax but does not go
through the whole pipelining shrine all
right so hopefully I introduced the
problem to you let's look in detail what
these syntactic scaffolds are so this is
essentially a multi task learning setup
where one of the tasks is the primary
task we are interested in which is the
semantic structured prediction does
frame semantics or koreff in our case
and the second task is syntactic
prediction however in contrast to your
traditional multi task learning setup
where both the tasks are equally
important for us the syntactic task is a
secondary auxilary task and the primary
task is the semantic task that we are
interested in so multi task learning
gives us this advantage that we can use
shared parameters to learn better
contextualized representations for the
spans and whatever sub structures that
are semantically non vacuous also in
this setup as in general Meletis
learning we do not need the supervision
for the semantics and syntax to come on
from the same data set so we can use two
different data sets one with only
semantic annotations and other with only
syntactic annotations and still be able
to learn which is difficult in your
regular pipeline setup because you need
the syntax on the same data before you
can predict semantics on it another
thing that the syntactic scaffolds
approach offers us is that we do not
have to predict this entire complicated
syntactic tree with all its bells and
whistles we just have to focus on the
sub structures in that syntactic tree
which are meaningful for the semantic
prediction tasks we look at some of the
sub structures later on and finally as
the name suggests
it's a scaffold so it is only used at
learning time to learn the model with
all the syntactic information in it and
a test time we can totally discard this
and move on all right so the learning
problem looks something like this so
this is the objective equation one shows
us the objective the first term in the
objective is the primary objective the
syntactic structure prediction objective
which we will look into later and the
secondary objective is the scaffold
objective both are interpolated by this
term Delta which is a mixing ratio that
tells you how do we weight these two
objectives so all you have to do is plug
in the scaffolding objective into your
semantic task semantic objective and you
will be able to learn information from
the syntactic tree bank and if you look
into the objective what it does is it's
a simple logistic regression classifier
it takes all possible spans in the
sentence up to a certain length and
tries to predict for each span what's
this a syntactic substructure of that
span could be whether or not it's a noun
phrase what kind of nan phrase it is
what the parent of the noun phrase could
be and so on so to formalize it the
different the different sub structures
we try to predict our phrase identity
whether or not a span is a constituent
phrase or a syntactic phrase the phrase
type of the span and if the span is not
a syntactic phrase we predict null the
phrase type and the parent phrase type
of the span this a parent phrase type is
the Constituent which immediately
precedes it in the tree and special
phrase types such as non trays and
prepositional phrase that is given a
span whether or not it is a noun phrase
or a prepositional phrase and we do this
because a lot of these arguments as we
the names Ivanka faithing they were non
phrases and a lot of semantic arguments
tend to be non phrases a lot of semantic
arguments tend to be prepositional
phrases and so on okay so let's look at
some of the the to downstream tasks that
we incorporated this framework in the
first one is frame semantics so again
this is what a frame semantics graph
looks like we are using the frame net
corpus which was proposed which was
created at Berkeley and in this
particular work we only focus on the
task of identifying and labeling these
pans so given a sentence as well as the
frames in the sentence that is if we
know that there is a frame telling in
the sentence and if we know there is a
frame subjective influence in the
sentence are we able to predict what the
arguments for those frames are and these
frame identification and also target
identification tasks are relatively
straightforward and have been solved
previously with high accuracy but
argument labeling and argument
identification are difficult tasks so we
focus only on that as a baseline we use
this model called semi markov CRFs which
is a generalization of a CRF so the
generalization only comes from the
simple fact that you have to predict for
a given sentence you predict a
segmentation of the sentence so in a
general CRF each segment is of the same
fixed length which is typically one a
semi Markov CRF offers you the freedom
of wearing the length modeling also the
length of the segment that you're
predicting so this works very well for
our case because arguments can have
arbitrary lengths so this is a natural
fit for the task of frame semantics
parsing without going into too many
details I'll just say that we focus on
spans of true
d so if you had to model every possible
span in the sentence of length and you
would run into o of n square complexity
and we pare it down to O of n D because
we only limit ourselves to spans of
length T and the factor L comes from the
different possible labels that you could
label a span with all right and to model
the spans themselves we use an
architecture like this this is from
co-authors Kenton and Luke rank so how
this model works is given a sentence we
first get the pre-trained embeddings for
that sentence we use Club here we pass
it through two bi-directional Alice
temps to get the contextualized
representations of each token in the
sentence these are given by the yellow
embeddings and to represent a span what
we do is we take the first word in the
span and the last word and concatenate
the hidden representation of both words
and we also use this head finding
mechanism that finds the head or it
chooses a simple attention mechanism to
figure out what would in the span
carries the most syntactic information
and that is given by the red nodes over
there and the final span representation
is given as the green rector's okay so
all we do in the scaffolded frame SRL is
plug in this objective so the primary
objective is shown on top it is a
simplified it's a modified a lot
likelihood objective and all we do now
is use the same span representations or
use the same parameters to learn these
pan representations and plug in the
scaffolding objective a scaffolding
objective is trained on on two nodes
data which is built on top of penn
treebank and the primary objective is
trained on frame and so here since we
have two different card
we can get by even though there is no
data overlap all right
so looking at some results our baseline
semi CRF model gets a significant
improvement over previous
state-of-the-art models and as we add
these different scaffolding models we
keep on seeing improvements so this
shows that adding syntactic information
is still useful and the best model that
we have which is shown in crate is this
particular scaffolding model which takes
a span and prigs whether or not it
should be a noun phrase or a
prepositional phrase so getting very
specific is seem to help
alright I'll quickly go over the next
task which is current resolution this is
also a span based task and so we use
this model from Canton and others where
this task is treated as a series of
sequence classification tasks so spans
in the sentence are labeled as entities
and also if you label for a given entity
what is the procedure the antecedent
entity to that particular entity so this
way you can build these simple
classification decisions to get entity
clusters so again all we do is since we
are doing a span based modeling for the
core efference model we can use the same
span representation to make the
classification of what kind of syntactic
span it is and so it's again very simple
just plug in and interpolate with Delta
again we see an improvement when we plug
in the scaffolding objective and the
improvement is not as much as we saw in
the frame net test and this could be
attributed to the fact that we do this
again on the on to notes
tasks where the way the core efference
mention current mentions were annotated
were on top of these syntactic
constituents so you already
have that information in the data and
you're reusing the data to learn these
syntactic constituents so it is possible
that that is why the improvement is not
as much so in summary we saw that syntax
is very useful for semantics but syntax
is expensive so scaffolds are an
inexpensive alternative that can get the
best of both worlds
okay so what's next so this is not
something that could is confined to only
semantic tasks basically any task that
uses syntactic span information could
benefit from such scaffolding syntactic
dependencies could be used as scaffolds
too and finally you can use semantics as
scaffolds for various downstream tasks
so that's all
[Applause]
um Canasta the differences between the
the recurrent neural network together
with the classification on top of on top
of it and recursive neural network
standard recursive right so you can
think of recursive neural nets as like a
special case for of recurrent neural
networks so basically to build a
recursive neural net you need to know
what structure it is modeling for which
you need to know that there is some kind
of a syntactic tree and you will use
that syntactic tree to compose together
the nodes but here we are just modeling
the sentences we don't have any
information about structure so we cannot
really use recursive neural nets in this
case but it is another way to represent
information like these graphical
information or tree specific information
so if you a great presentation if you
wanted to enhance where you were going
beyond the frame induction and and
capturing work semantics like possession
and negation and some of these other
types of things would you need to go
more into doing you know grammatical
dependency types of relationships rather
than the span based representations so
we've actually been thinking about doing
similar things for these natural
language inference based tasks where
relationships between words is shown to
be enough to predict inference
relationships between these hypotheses
and premises and that is where the
syntactic dependencies careful's is
hope to help the most because yeah
you're not when it really depends on
that uh so here we had to span based
tasks and so we saw that these pan based
scaffolding things help but it really
depends on the end task so you typically
want to if you want to do very good
multitasking you typically want to learn
structures which are kind of similar but
there is nothing to say that if you
learn from different structures you
can't get anything I don't have
experimental results to show that but
it's also possible I was just curious if
you've done only POS tagging as as the
other objective instead of
constituencies yeah so that's a good
question so there has been related work
that does POS tagging as one of the
tasks and this multitask learning
scenario we did not do that because we
were more interested in these more
complicated structural tasks but people
have used POS as one of the maybe the
auxilary part of the scaffolding testers
work from your off goldberg and others
who have done similar things and saw
improvements but yeah that's also
another alternative right
you